okay we have been saying that we're
going to try to at least keep the
voicemail segment light because of all
of the horrible news that is coming out
so here's a call I got at our voicemail
line two one nine to david p about
whether I'm still eating sang sandwiches
in a particular way take a list Ollie to
sorry David my name is Colton Han I was
just calling to just inquire if you've
changed your stance on your sandwich
eating style flipping it upside down
just thinking about it it's a pretty
regressive disgusting way of eating a
sandwich and I was wondering if at all
you have any any number no yes so listen
I am still eating sandwiches in the same
way and one of the things I'm known for
and I'm trying to see if I can let's see
if I can do a little demo here for you
very quickly as people may know imagine
that the writing on this piece of paper
on top of the piece of paper is are the
sesame seeds on top of a sesame seed bun
so if you have the sandwich sort of bun
up on in front of you the way I have
always eaten sandwiches is I take it and
I flip it as I bring it to my mouth I
flip it so the sesame seed bun ends up
pointing down if that makes sense a lot
of people have been horrified that this
is how I eat sandwiches but it has not
changed I continue to eat sandwiches in
that way I've been making great
sandwiches during my self quarantine and
I'm still flipping the sandwich every
way if that I know some people will
probably cancel memberships over that
but that is what I'm doing quick
reminder Wednesday evening March 25 8:00
p.m. Eastern David Pakman show chess
tournament I will stream the tournament
live on all four of our video platforms
anybody can play anybody can play
join me 8:00 p.m. and make an account on
Lee chess org to be ready great bonus
show for you today thanks for watching
we're here all week